[Music]
in doing big things new do a big guy I
want to do small things like what it's
submitted by Jamal Ian Sun Sand Sam's
and the better way of saying sail to
Bali Indonesia
they've sand their yeah by speaking up
on the beaches somebody live in the ball
son Bali sand okay youtuber Lilly Singh
will house a new NBC late-night blue oh
oh so it's real yes crazy
cuz I saw her photos came out of nowhere
nowhere I mean not for her right I mean
it's been like three years is she
replacing a late-night host or okay
she's replacing Carson Daly thank God
for the 1:35 a.m. talk show what lately
slowly I never liked the Carson Daly
I've never seen one a.m. I didn't even
know Carson Daly had a late-night show
this has got to beat them biggest social
media to traditional media crossover
right yeah youtuber youtuber he was he
was a huge ooh - yeah that's how he got
big first I mean he was but he didn't go
to the invasion prey you know he wasn't
so early on I wouldn't even call him a
Ubud if you never heard dumb freestyle
backstage you didn't go to a YouTube
event so he wasn't above the asian crowd
but he went his cries original yeah
biggest influence was patch up oh I do
know that if you saw his bio [ __ ] it was
his favorite artist he's the second
biggest across she's a bit second
biggest crossover that but he does have
traditional background but he used
YouTube as a platform to get more eyes
on them what about Tori Kelly
Tori Kelly
for chief under one like two Grammys
doo-doo-doo she yeah that's up in
Toronto she's the fourth biggest one
I've seen I'm telling you guys the fifth
one that I've seen some team Internet
roll-call sorry Lilly Singh you're not
that special anymore
but basically when I saw this though
like I got a little skeptical not about
her but I feel like sometimes because
that show is already failing and it's
been failing for a while and that slot
is really hard I thought Late Late Late
hoping are setting her up to fail
it's a consolation prize
exactly it's a 1 a.m. though that's what
I'm hoping it's not and on top of that
they also know that her fan base is like
the age of like [ __ ] 4 5 to like 10
that's what I was saying so why are they
gonna bring up that leg exactly so I
hope they're not setting her up to fail
so that's the part where I get a little
bit skeptical you know because if they
wanted her to succeed they want to put
out a 2 a.m. time slot when they know
her demographic yeah so it's a little
weird it'd be at 6 a.m. right before
school elementary school 3 p.m. but she
has clout and it sounds dope it does
sound dumb but that's what I'm saying
that's what I'm saying I don't want this
to be a setup for her failure because we
don't know what the Hollywood intentions
are yeah I don't know if it's fired at
10:00 but I do think it's more around
like high school age her Bambi's oh yeah
yeah probably well cuz I remember when
she had like a hundred thousand subs
yeah that was like when I still lived in
Ohio I think they are like high school
age but also nobody has cable so I'm
nervous that yeah I don't know what the
Hollywood intentions are but like if
nobody has cable and it's at two watches
TV no one dude [ __ ] I hope they stream
it because if they stream it then her
fans would watch it and then we'll Eunos
be like oh a youtuber made it right but
then like when they stream it and then
it's on the YouTube homepage it's it's
already too late to get the views and so
like the networks will be like oh no
one's tuning into this and the mole
either
cancel it because they're like oh we
didn't know that it has the YouTube
plush because like once it goes on
YouTube people will watch it cuz that's
where her fans are yeah but I don't know
like if they're gonna stay up or get NBC
to watch it because they think it's like
I never thought of her to be somebody
who would do late-night talk-show stuff
specifically because I saw her on this
clip with Trevor Noah
oh and then she came on there and she
spoke and she kind of bombed like I was
kind of shocked because I think like she
was trying to make jokes to an adult an
adult audience and then crickets right
so I was like oh [ __ ]
so maybe the late-night show it'll be
freedom yeah she could cater to her own
jokes amoeba girona oh yeah she did
mention that her show would be pretty
much her youtube channel like she's
gonna do sketches and oh really oh cool
that's pretty cool I'm interested to see
so the lot that she's replacing it were
used to be called Last Call with Carson
Daly and it ran for 17 years
oh my god I guess there's still people
watching affiliates for drunk rednecks
or each other
that are watching at 1:30 a.m. who's
watching regular cable TV at 1:30 and
well some people leave it on to go to
sleep oh yeah also - you know what I
found out noise Fellsmere Florida a lot
of people watch TV all Pharrell we have
cable yeah but we don't watch a 1:30
a.m. but there's a lot of places that
where people still watch a lot of TV so
we watch TV but 1:30 a.m. TV that's cuz
you guys response it's really weird
no no if we wanted to stay up we'd watch
the actual TV show on a streaming
platform you know 1:30 a.m. TV you're
drunk you're regretting something you
just did you have a knife to your wrist
shaving the hairs off yeah come on Oh
people jeez but I'm thinking about
50-plus who's who's kind of they're
comfortable with watching TV and that's
what they like to do and then they might
browse around Netflix from time to time
but they're used to just having some
programming but are you still watched
like late-night talk shows all the time
like even like that Craig Ferguson
dealership listen to his [ __ ] all the
time so maybe it's still popping like oh
you know what might happen cuz like
Jimmy Fallon and stuff they put those
clips
on YouTube oh oh yeah it might have some
how about always repenting always there
always trending they might do well on
you though that's that might be their
strategy they might be switching stuff
up you know these of them like would do
things they don't set her up yeah yeah
yeah Russ you didn't get that slot dude
I would picture you doing that really
legit when I thought that I thought you
would better suit that because you
actually did your own version of a mini
talk show thing it's so janky hit my
living room
it was janky as [ __ ] David walked in he
was like this is trap it was so funny
though she would have liked this look
there's like duct tape all hanging
around because it looks really great on
camera right but we're in the backs that
came in outside do this girl's [ __ ]
ghetto dude I was like she's actually
don't make it work yeah he wasn't wrong
you would have never known but it was
tight belly tight so Lily sings show
will be called a little late with Lilly
Singh which is so cute yeah that's not
what girls want to hear though right oh
yes I will launch in September and yet
so they're saying that she is the only
female to currently host a late-night
talk show was there ever a female talk
show late night there's a lot daytime
melanin ooh
it's not memorable so not only is she
the first youtuber first woman to maybe
double whammy to be well grace went
linear but that was a daytime show right
grace Helbig who should bomb like a
[ __ ] I don't even know what a show
dude that's what I'm like guys be nice
to assault internet people because yeah
maybe they don't like I don't know they
do it on purpose maybe you did
energize way to do it rivers was one
Joan Rivers Alicia with Joan Rivers she
was the first woman rebel to lately
network television that make sense and
during the time when Grace had her [ __ ]
it was super green super super yeah yeah
so times are a little different now TV
didn't even have their own [ __ ] figured
out another plugin in like a new
variable to you I felt like grace had a
really high probability of a crossover
those Grace's show I never I don't
remember because I never got to watch it
cuz it take that fast it was it kind of
so like every time something fails when
a youtuber does it they automatically
think all these other people are gonna
fail but it's like man there's millions
of people on the platform with different
talents and skills one of these articles
and I was researching about Lilly Singh
there was this radio show that had they
made an article about it and while they
were talking about it they were saying
like yeah so she's a youtuber but don't
they were pretty much saying like
because she's a youtuber like don't hold
that against her she's actually really
might in other bones I know I'm like I
hate that we get so much disrespect for
beer YouTube well when we all first
started we didn't want to be youtubers
we just use it as a way to go some real
things but people actually want to be a
youtuber now it's just a title do kids
write that [ __ ] they go what do you want
to be when you grow up youtuber I'm like
dude that's a [ __ ] career choice son
it is Isaac's cool
every time we go for any of his events
and stuff they're like oh that's weird
like it was so cute cuz his little girl
she looked like she was in third grade
or something she came up to us she's
like hi Tiffany cuz he was right behind
me she's like and whatever I forgot your
name but nobody got like there just see
us like you know being a youtuber is a
big deal that [ __ ] story you talk
they were so inspiring I do it just like
you know
me I'm like why is she watching her
stuff is not allowed to watch her stuff
but he tells me that song as friends
watch it and I'm like don't think about
you're making them so cool well they see
him as a youtuber to do I can't wait for
your kid to have some straight damn
teeth man he's all getting there thank
god dude you know the wire it's like
poking them behind which means like his
teeth are getting straighter oh okay
what a hard start hurt somebody gets
caught like that
no more blender blades to think I was
waiting for that day dude Isaac's teeth
were crazy I know I know
did you have crazy teeth when you were
you know those are really crazy dude his
feet look like they're having a [ __ ]
like a riot inside his mouth man they
look like two West's argue with each
other so it's like turning to each other
I've never seen two teeth go in like
this
the 222 seats on a train so we put the
brackets on right and they were like
touching wood brackets were tied but I
can't wait good number one I think is a
really handsome boy so imagine when the
teeth the fix man takes he is hello
jingle asics oh but you know what dude
Isaac classes are kind of cool on them
yeah actually really good oh yeah so I
don't know bro you may not need it man I
can't wait
Oh
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]